hey youtubers this charlie happy Game of
Thrones day we're almost there just a
little bit more so this is gonna be my
last bonus video before my episode 1
review tonight so I think we're all
about to explode from excitement so what
I'm gonna do is my top 10 moments from
season 3 just as one final look back and
then after that I'm going to explain the
contest the giveaway rules again as well
as my Game of Thrones video schedule so
let's not waste any time and just get
right into it
careful for spoilers from season 3 if
you're not cut up yet but number 10 Jon
Snow becomes a man a Seminole time in
the life of any teenager this wasn't so
much a Jon Snow losing his virginity
moment as it was at Ygritte taking his
virginity moment you get the sense that
she was the real brains of that
operation and Jon Snow was just happy to
oblige it's a nice reversal of gender
roles for instance you know had
everything played out in King's Landing
and Ygritte been a member of the court
it probably would have been told from a
much more male perspective you know even
though Cersei does willed a lot of
sexual authority over men she's much
older right now I don't remember it
being spelled out explicitly in the
books but I think it's implied that when
she was Jon Snow and Ygritte sage Jaime
was her only sexual partner you know at
least before she was married to Robert
Baratheon as much fun as it was to watch
that scene in the cave it was even more
fun listening to kit harington and Rose
Leslie talked about how awful and
awkward it was on set that day I think
Kit Harington actually had a cast on his
leg when they filmed that scene he had
broken his leg so imagine him you know
just like limping into the hot spring
number 9 Brienne versus the bear this
was kind of a meta moment
because you know first off you have
badass Brienne holding her own against a
freaking bear with a wooden sword just
so awesome
then you have Jaime's change of heart
and rescue in reality it wasn't really
his fighting skills that saved him you
know he would have been shredded in
seconds it was just the threat of what
Tywin Lannister would do if you were
hurt at least more than he already had
been I loved how the whole event just
invoked this classic sense of chivalry
that bran believed in so much or
believes in so much most of the time
she's the one being chivalrous though
but it was such a huge moment for both
of them you know friend not dying and
Jaime you know finally doing something
selfless for a change number 8 the
Nights Watch rebellion dirty old Craster
in the old bear
never saw it coming you know first we
have to acknowledge that it was burn
gorman of Torchwood authoring that
debacle that was just a nice meta Doctor
Who fandom moment but then you have the
ocean realization that with Jorah
Mormont dead in the Nights Watch an open
revolt
who the hell is going to get everyone
ready for the wildling attack you know
I'm not even talking about the army
itself they don't even have a chance
against that small raiding party that
Jon Snow was part of I think we all
shared a moment of triumph whenever old
Craster bit you know which quickly
turned to the horror on samwell's faces
he ran off with killing into the
distance number seven
Thoros of muir brings back beric
Dondarrion flaming swords aside this was
totally a huge deal because it
established that the dead can be made
whole again you know not just reanimated
White's like the white walkers do but
brought back to their normal state beric
Dondarrion did say that there were some
side effects like pieces of you that
would get left behind each time you came
back like pieces of your soul got left
behind Melisandre was pretty amazed when
she found out how many times barek had
been bought back so it does seem like
each priest or priestess of the red God
expresses their powers in different ways
but I think she'll be able to do it too
before wins a winner or dream of spring
is over so the big takeaway from all
this was is that if you're worried about
a certain character or you think they're
gonna die as long as they're in
proximity to a follower of the red God
there's a chance that they could come
back so just remember that number six
Jon Snow climbs the wall this is one of
the biggest action set pieces of the
season and involved a lot of you know
really cool CGI integration I remember
reading about the sheer size of the wall
in the books but until the show came
along you really just had to imagine
what it looked like in your head I think
they did a really great job of
interpreting of just how massive it is
in the books george RR martin made it
about 700 feet tall and i feel like it
became a whole character in and of
itself like the wall itself is a
character in the story all I can think
about now though is one when are we
going to get to see or read about it
being built and two will we ever see
someone blow the true Horn of winter and
bring it crashing down it's still a
legend you know it's unconfirmed that
actually blowing the real Horn of winter
will destroy the wall but let me know if
you think that's going to happen in the
future
number five Ramsay snow tortures Theon
all season long
the final act of all this torture was
clearly the worst but
there's no promise that after that the
torture won't continue into the early
part of season 4 so as far as we know
he's still being tortured right now as
bad as Theon was before season 3 I feel
like he's endured enough everything
about that character he is right now it
just makes you feel sorry for him sorry
for the circumstances that made him feel
like he had to betray his adopted family
and sorry for what Ramsay snow has been
doing to him there is the promise though
that he will make it out of that torture
dungeon because we did see clips from
him in the trailer with him riding
around on a horse and he wasn't running
from Ramsay number 4 Samwell kills a
white Walker one of his only wins of the
season but one of the biggest I remember
the first time I saw this I had to
rewind and watch it again because I
couldn't tell if he dropped that
obsidian dagger before he ran off with
Gilly Samwell for all of his faults is
one of the first new people in the story
to figure out that one of the big white
walkers weaknesses is obsidian or dragon
classic you know whatever you want to
call it I'm really hoping that he's able
to educate other people in the Nights
Watch you know even a few people before
the white walkers come because there was
that really ominous shot from the
trailer we don't know if there's gonna
be a major white Walker attack though in
season four number three Jamie gets his
hand chopped off this had to be one of
the defining moments for the first part
of the season the death of Ned Stark
kind of already told us that no one was
safe but getting his hand chopped off
let you know that george RR martin and
the show were not afraid to permanently
maim their lead characters it's such an
ocean moment just because of the
spectacle and because they just slammed
a black right as Jaime started screaming
but it made me wonder you know what the
hell was going to happen to that
character it's not like they have
hospitals and in the books the brave
companions basically just treat Brienne
and Jaime like trash until they get back
to Roose Bolton number two Daenerys
becomes the breaker of chains I'm mostly
referring to a stupor and Dany taking
the unsullied and exacting some revenge
against crassness it was one of those
big moments that HBO spoiled in all
their teaser clips so we all kind of
knew about it ahead of time but that
moment she activated drogon you know so
to speak using high Valyrian was just so
amazing and such a huge win it ended up
blooming into this amazing CG sequence
of her just burning everything in sight
and marching away with this massive army
it was such a huge triumph for her
character given that in Westeros there's
still all that
civil war going on and my number one
moment no one surprised here totally
read wedding all the way I don't think
there's any season three WTF list that
does not list this as the number one
moment it was the most talked about
moment on television last year and most
people don't even get HBO or even watch
the show before the red wedding george
RR martin in the show already had you
know memes for slaughtering main
characters wholesale but the red wedding
became this meta cultural event all over
the world
first there were all the reaction videos
like Maisie Williams Queen of vines
totally amazing and then there were all
the parodies you can really gauge the
popularity of something by how much it
gets parodied and just in terms of
television this was the most parodied
event last year I think my favorite was
probably Maisie Williams you know her
reaction was only six seconds long but
it perfectly summed up the spirit of
every single other parody that followed
but now it's your turn let me know what
was your favorite moment from season
three and what moment are you looking
forward to most in season four you know
I know everyone's thinking purple
wedding which is kind of funny because
all the book readers are just kind of
grumbling because george RR martin never
called it the purple wedding in the
books but it's just an example of how
pop culture can take something and
change it in the larger context so now
here's the details on the giveaway with
the rules it's super simple just as a
way to say thank you to all you guys i'm
picking one random subscriber from the
comments on each of my episode reviews
all you have to do to participate is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on my
episode 1 review episode 2 and so on
winners will be announced monday nights
during my Q&A videos so here's the rules
you can only want to giveaway once so if
you've already want something from me in
the past
you can't win again you also have to be
nice so this is just meant to be a fun
way for us to talk about a show we
really love so if I feel like you're
being too mean or you're trolling I'll
just delete your comment or at worst
I'll ban you from the channel so please
be nice it's so much more fun when
people are nice so tonight I'll be
posting my episode 1 review about 3
hours or so after it airs you can follow
me on Twitter or Facebook for updates on
when videos are coming
sometimes it takes a bit of longer if
there's problems I usually try to post
updates just so you guys know when stuff
is happening so while we're all holding
our breath waiting for episode 1 you can
click here to learn about my top 10
characters and you can click here to
watch all my other season 4 videos thank
so much for watching I'll see you guys
tonight high fives